from Florida  quarterback see how you guys in this  pocket look you got feet now you got  feet too now look  see how that boy running like he running  from the cops  all right  he was about six five six six years you  need to be watching Odell yeah watch how  you catch that thing his hands is like  so he caught that thing like that  uh  BMF it just doesn't just keep your feet  and Bounds now  pay attention is Willie beaming right  here  where the bean was a quarterback for the  sharks  um  pay attention we're watching Boobie  Miles  that thing  and you see somebody coming like that  oh and he could pay  the way it's crazy  just stay down oh get up and scrap  that's the only thing you got to do see  how you just folded that man whole body  like that that's a grown man  which one do you want who you want to  play football